this topic is it's kind of peaceful but
a lot of it is what Allah is very very
theoretical and I in some ways like
we've gotten too used to hell
theoretical one of the things up and
it's sewed the whole closet about nice
you'll on taking some of these concrete
and make it as abstract as let's see
that's the reason why the example that's
expressed my life is that mathematics is
about is about seeing through skylight
x-ray glasses it's at speed through like
the external details mc3 and realizing
actually these two things that look
nothing alike but actually bound by the
same principle okay so for example what
you think of a population it's growing
because it's got space to grow that's
all populations do we know what kind of
curves at that trace it's now right so
you gave this extra edge with me because
the population is the bigger it can grow
okay so there's one idea we learned that
in Exponential's we're going to go into
it as a whole the second part of that
the decay pond to think of radioactive
materials and how they they decay over
time their half-life it's all right so
these are those to these populations and
radioactive materials like on the face
of it look nothing alike
right but the mathematics of them is the
same so pull of those as a result are
one of those abstract objects we can
look at because we strip away all of the
external started when you say well look
at them because they look at the heart
of it is okay but I think it's really
important especially for you guys to
realize oh why are we doing this again
so I kind of want to spend like a good
at least if you tip in it just just
taking a step out of it
just taking a step back and thinking
about like why are we doing this kid
before we dive straight in so where we
are losted x's and ends and all the
different kinds of operators we're
looking at you okay so I guess then hey
if you made already the heavy
polynomials I guess a bucket makes
something underneath that which is why
we so interested in polynomials because
in a real way kinda like hell things
done is so much of what you've been
doing for many many easy mess it's been
building through this and then we've
done just build to it we've like spent a
long time thinking about toss things
right so my question is why are we so
interested and I've got two answers for
you hey what kind of eternal two that
banks and the other one is so he's mater
no reason when you think about of just
the way mathematics works like where did
it begin and the answer is a Pima County
okay the fancy welfare is a beginning
arithmetic and saying okay look here at
numbers and we use them good morning to
quantify things right that's where every
game now when you take numbers and then
you say well it's normal to try to
operate on these sums combine them in
different ways right these are the
familiar operations of arithmetic
everything starts with addition right
because you can add these together
subtraction is just a specialized form
of addition it's the interest
multiplication what's its relationship
to addition
and times of the same yeah very good
multiplication is just repeated addition
right an exponentiation is just repeated
so these all forms from just a very very
like as simple as it can possibly be
operational yeah that's arithmetic but
then the next about that is well what if
you don't know what the numbers are and
that's how algebra is born okay
and tada polynomials right there you are
it doesn't take very long it kind of
like the natural out working or what
happens with you have numbers you try
and do things to enter a connect the
numbers together and then you wonder
what happens when you don't know what
the numbers are and you can still label
it away so my first internal reason is
polynomials they're their natural
outworking like they're kind of the
embodiment of all of these rules and
principles and ideas arithmetic and
algebra if you start with those which
are kind of fundamental to what
mathematical like that is straight then
you bother doing polynomials like this
is what it looks like this is the stuff
of that land so they're the natural
monument of the principles and ideas
and I'm just gonna ride everything to
get out for life okay so to try and give
this to y'all's trip think about what
this looks like right I came up with
this kind of metaphor right and you guys
know you'll love because you did how
much I like English right polynomials up
build algebraic terms like you saw
indexes excuse so I was right terms are
kinda like that when we want and then
polynomials are kind of to sweet here in
units right he is one object even those
loving plants to it they are all going
to behave together okay Ashbury terms of
pollinators part of mathematics what
words and sentences hard to English this
is what I think is dynamic in knowledge
and sentences appear everywhere in
English in exactly the same way right
like sentences and that's our employment
of like grammar and vocabulary and
language you can't you can't speak
without sentences you just sort of
naturally stop doing that and then it
just kind of flows on that's where the
literature comes from all these
techniques that are sort of flowed out
about okay so I heard that analogy once
you understand the first reason why
polynomials are such a big deal or just
random polynomials are not one topic
among many mathematics they kind of like
fundamental the way words and sentences
are to the subject does that kind of
make sense so there's my eternal reason
that's why you spend so much time
thinking about polynomials understanding
them wrestling with the
but it's not the biggest reason and so
I'm going to go to the second reason
which is kind of Expo this is internal
this is internal and this is excellent
the second reason we spend too much time
on that magnet is that polynomials are
ridiculously effective effective at
modeling the natural world in the
Natural Sciences you wouldn't
necessarily expect that mathematics
would be useful because mathematics
comes out of laws that we just made up
we've just made them up our people who
are in my class a couple of years ago
who didn't beat debate about this
mathematics invented or is it discovered
and the answer is is clearly both okay
but the invention side cannot be
overestimated
like we've made up these rules we made
this structure and like we imagined a
lot of it and we didn't think of
anything do in real life and yet like
when you do something as utilized let me
pick the object that was present when
you just leave as simple as take like
air up this marital budget and you throw
it in the air the puff hood traces out
is exactly a parabola that's when you
that's really when we look at projectile
motion right we will prove that okay
like it's not close to it's exactly the
problem it's exactly one of those simple
kind of polynomials
you might be thinking we have okay but
that's very simple I want to go back to
something that we looked at recently
these guys right and I wonder if you
would because we were going through like
this is like where do these come up with
each other you really go around saying
oh look there's a double car just
randomly the move of the whispering
galleries they're kind of cool
right but they're man-made like they
have those particular geometric
properties because we designed them to
have them right so the question is like
well employer is responsible
well and context I like sort of kind of
do out of the same rules and vocabulary
then where are these and the answer is
of you'll live on a conic section it's
about 300 million kilometers across
because in fact every time you look up
in the sky you're looking at millions of
conic sections every object that orbits
something there's pulled by gravity is
on a conic section we have no vertical
orbit I wrote down the number actually
the eccentricity of Earth's pivot is
what is it it's zero point when I write
down oh that's right our eccentricities
0.017 that it's interesting you out
orbit around the Sun we're out we win a
yellow one thing about the Sun okay the
moon's orbit around us is quite a bit
more accentuated this year was here five
I think it's five foot nine okay that's
you if Jesus is really large boot right
it's really weird because all this the
wrong way around it
it's orbital eccentricity zero point
zero zero zero zero one six which is a
contender but probably the most
perfectly circular object in the entire
solar system like when you can see that
how big it is and the pot that races out
how close he is torso is his mother
all right so remember how I said right
like all of these look at the decor you
like you're crazy that's that's a but
that particular is a colored box we
don't have the same kind of it's low on
the right over plane the answer is yes
so every almost every object in the
solar system has an elliptical path
around around the center of mass but not
all of them do because some objects are
just kind of passing through and they'll
come around and they'll sort of be
influenced by the Sun's gravity but not
enough to keep it in orbit so they will
come around now come around
they'll be bent around but then their
path whatever speed back right so they
trace out a hyperbolic bottle or a
parabolic path in fact speaking about
parallel paths what would you say if I
said she was the most famous comment
what would you say probably right
Halley's Comet has an auto eccentricity
of I wrote it down to a trillion screwed
up zero point nine six seven then you
guys know what it's interesting means
that what happens when it gets really
close to a special number what wiII
happen if this is just a little warm
what happens orbitons it would turn into
a parabola in fact this is a pretty good
image of what how these comets
looks like which at this point I think
we all agree looks a heck of a lot like
a parabola that's because he is almost
improbably it was just going a little
bit faster it would rip around but would
shoot off at such a speed that that's
Suns grabbing would never be able to
pull it back okay every objects in the
solar system is on a conic section with
the Sun adver can you guess it's at
either if it was a pair of my party to
be at the focus or being that we are in
elliptical orbit it's on one of the
photon right which makes you wind up
the other focus which is so I guess a
trade to establish right like we
thinking about polynomials because
polynomials like because of this
combination of bats that they are
everywhere they come up just naturally
in mathematics in the same way that I
think in nature if I'm if I'm
remembering right like the size that I
do I think
apart from gold and platinum we always
find our moving elements in nature just
by themselves just sitting on the earth
because most of these react right like
you don't even get what to do on its own
or to itself and in the same way we
write like all the peoples were like a
big compound sorry polynomials they're
just everywhere they just pop up all the
time you never really get like all of is
an X by itself right they're always
clinging on to other things form
employers that are interesting in
dimension so that's why we're going to
invest more time into the tools